Adam, as punishment for eating the apple
when I had commanded you not to,
you will toil in the fields.  And it will be hard.
I understand, my God.
And Eve, I will greatly increase your pain in childbearing.
And each month your cycle shall come and cause you to bleed.
Wait, what?
Doesn't that seem a little disproportionate?
No, no!  I'm not done yet!
Adam, you will wear this around your neck!
I call it a tie.  It's kind of annoying.
Uhg, I pull it up?
All the way right to your apple.
Ugh.
This is mildly annoying.
And Eve, you will wear these on your feet!
Okay.
Doesn't look comforta--
Yeah.  That's--yep!  And get those--
Okay.  Oh.  Okay.
Yeah.
Oh!  They hurt so bad!
Yes, they're very painful when you put them on.
Your legs look great though.
Aw, thanks babe.
They really do.
Thank you!  Guys!  Stop!
And finally, Eve, there will come a time
in your life when you will feel compelled to lay with many men
and you will.
And everyone you know will talk shit about you behind your back
and call you a whore-bitch-slut-hoe and men will say you're easy.
Will I have a compulsion to lay with many women too?
Oh yes.  24/7.
What are people going to say about Adam?
That he's a motherfucking pimp!
God, this seems pretty unfair to Eve.
I mean, did something happen to you?  Are you okay?
What?  No!  Shut up, Adam!  What's your problem?
What?--You want even more punishment?
No, no--I don't.
Huh?  Fine!  Okay!
Uhm.
When women are mad at you, they will tell you everything is fine
but guess what?
They're lying.
That still feels like a barb at me, though.
Hate the game, not the player.
Yeah but you're God.  You made the game.
Whatever.
Oh my God, I am so sorry.
Listen, we just broke up and I was trying to get the attention off me.
He banished me from up there!  Can you believe that?
My ex is such a little bitch!
I did not know he was gonna like lash out at you.
Like crazy!
Ugh!
You do not deserve this. I am so sorry.  Like seriously.
My bad.
You know, I just like want to make it really clear that I am so sorry.
I mean how can anyone think that this is okay?
Right?
Yeah!  Right?
You'll be fine.
Good luck!